dan please sack back here on the show
how are you Dan rich I'm doing great
minutes to trade deadline again already
we did this last year didn't we crazy
right
I think Bryce Harper to buzz you know
the one that I've been surprised is
getting so much play Chris Archer it
sounds like the Brewers are really in on
Chris Archer the Cubs are kicking the
tires on Chris arts or so the two big
names that I think that are out there
people are waiting to see if it happens
Chris Archer seems more than likely like
he's going to be moved in the next two
hours and this Bryce Harper stuff though
I can't see it rich I just think there
are five and a half games back that
being the Nationals it's not like
they're chasing the 92 or 93 Braves or
they 84-82 Phillies the Phillies and
Braves are good teams but they would be
also Rance in the AL so I think the Nats
are like 110 game stretch wretch where
they go eight and two or nine and one
and they'd find themselves three games
out of first place and they'd be right
in I would be shocked if they moved
arbor what do you think what happens
when a player of his ilk is being thrown
around and and they're having a
listening tour I mean how does that
happen so what I'm saying is is a team
that you say that needs to rip off a to
10 and 9 to 10 that hasn't shown the
ability to do that will find that
gumption if if a trade doesn't happen
Dan you know what I think if I'm Bryce
Harper he's a different bird than you
and I are most players because I think
deep down inside rich I think he really
wants to test the free agent market I
don't think he's going to take a home
team discount I don't think he's going
to play this thing out go listen man
I've had a good run I just won the home
run derby for the Nationals it's a good
story he's going my opinion Scott Boras
they're gonna test the market because if
they were interested at all in a
discount or hey I want to stay here this
is where I'm comfortable we would have
heard talks about that already and he
would be scratching the fact that listen
I want to play my career here I'd like
to stick this thing out I think rich I
don't think he's gonna be upset that
he's getting dangled and I think in his
own little way he might even it might
even like fuel some fire underneath him
because I don't think it's eminent that
he's coming back and I
really think he's gonna test the water
he wants to test the water to see what's
out there form that's just my pick let
me ask you this question then Dan please
suck cuz this is gonna be the three to
four hundred million dollar question
coming up in the hot stove if you're a
general manager of a team
would you would you allocate a fifth of
your your money that that your owners
gonna give you to make sure you don't go
over any luxury tax would you allocate
it to Bryce Harper uh well that's the
tough question because he you know what
he is he's I guess if you want to look
at like certain players they're big
their brand of their branding I think
wherever he would go other than DC he's
going to be an instant hit because he's
the one guy you know Mike Trout is
looked at as the best player in the game
but Mike Trout is so low-keyed you don't
really know much about Mike Trout
Bryce Harper he's on commercials he's
out there his face is relevant young
people know who he is
so I think he's a different bird I don't
think a four hundred million dollar
contract is going to be out there rich
but I think some teams and it may be the
Nats Nationals and it may be three or
four other teams I think they'd approach
the forty to forty five million a year
but I don't think anybody's going to be
in for like eight to ten years but I
could see him a four or five year deal
and I'm sure Scott Boras will have it
where he could have opt outs after a
year or two I think the average annual
is going to be somewhere around forty
million but I don't think we're gonna
see a ten year four hundred million
dollar guaranteed contract from one team
several buyouts teams will want to take
them on but much of a shorter term
country so Dan please a can will be
network here do you think the Dodgers
would be involved in something like that
even if they they would be I think I
think they're gonna look at it this way
I really think when the season is over
either or Machado and or Harper now I
don't know this because I don't know the
Phillies ownership internally but rich
they want to spend and they want to get
better in the worst way and I would be
surprised shocked both if either Machado
or Harper aren't going to Clearwater in
spring training with the Philadelphia
Phillies in 2019 I think both guys are
on their radar I'm not sure crichton
curse
has an opt-out which I'm not sure you
will now because of the issues he's had
with his back if the Dodgers are really
keen about staying under that luxury
payroll threshold then maybe Machado
isn't their guy but I don't look I don't
look at Machado necessarily as he's
going to stay Pat and stay with the
Dodgers I think he's going to also test
the market and I think the Phillies if
there's one team that could bowl the
market up for both of these guys and
create some I guess competition it's
going to be the Phillies because they
want to get better and they're they're
holding back so badly they want to spend
money and get better really quick
they're gonna drive the stock up on both
of these I don't know man obviously
October's gonna have a lot to say about
it Dan but and if I'm the Dodgers I my
money into Machado I tell the
Guggenheim's to turn over a couch
cushion or dive into whatever Maybach
they're driving around and fine and go
over the tacks or whatever they'd have
to do and figure out how you work corey
seager into it and go to work i mean
that guy and it's certainly if they have
the October that we're all expecting and
Dave Roberts knows what he's what he's
doing on that front I mean you got a
chance that you know you cover sports on
a daily basis but I think for the Dodger
fan that gets a chance to watch this guy
I thought going into the trade line
there were two guys that were like
really difference makers the player was
Machado and the pitcher was Jacob degrom
and I don't think the Mets have any
interest in moving degrom there's no
doubt in my mind if you were to ask me
right now of all the guys that are so
what a so-called available Machado is
number one on my list and he's number
one by a longshot I think he hits better
for average he has as much power he's
more consistent than Bryce Harper
Bryce Harper goes through these eight
ten game stretches well hit seven eight
home runs but there's too many stretches
of eight to ten games where he doesn't
do a whole lot do you only mean like at
the end of the year we're gonna look at
Harper's numbers and go well you hit 14
he knocked in 100 but you know the 225
batting average 230 batting average I
don't know I don't know rich if you were
asking me
Machado would be my guy no I don't agree
with you more well I mean certainly look
LeBrons coming here trout's already in
Southern California
and with all due respect you know
Kershaw is only once every five days
with all due respect to all the other
position players I mean just in turn is
very popular here and I know what
Bellinger did last year and Puig when he
puts games together people go crazy for
him out here in Los Angeles
I think if Machado puts together the
September in October that everybody
expects the it'll be a no-brainer to
keep him and I don't know if Harper
would come here or if they should even
make that play I do have to ask you this
Dan you know with a feel silly but I
gotta ask you cuz it did take up so much
oxygen over the weekend what do you make
of the whole batting practice attire
gait if you will Joseph you don't dance
rich it's a different time now do you
know what I mean and I and I guess I can
get where the old-school guy looks at
that and says hey they do the gates are
open batting practice rich it's a
different time and I think you have to
adjust what the times and for some of
the old-school broadcasters and guys
that have been around baseball for a
while
listen it's not just the Dodgers you we
have a ballpark camera we do live
look-ins in the afternoon I get it the
gates aren't always open it's a
different culture of young people now
rich I mean it's just not the mock
turtle necks and you know it's just not
the way it was and I think sometimes you
just got lighten up and that's just
that's the way the world is right now
that's that's all it isn't and I know in
in my dealings I've been at the network
here now for nine years and things are
different and it's about change and I
think when you start to get in your 40s
and 50s and you get you you think like
you've seen it all and you want it the
way that it used to be and you want it
to be you know like Carl Yastrzemski and
Jim Rice and you want it to be Mickey
Mantle and the Duke and all that you
know what that's not the world we live
in right now rich that's that's the best
way I could put it you have to kind of
adjust with the time and I'm also Dan
loath to bring up you know trade
deadline
controversies because last year was
right around this time when the Astros
didn't make a move and Dallas Keuchel
kind of was like what gives as they've
just the front office even support us
and then Verlander came before the
September 1 call-up by mere seconds
anyway and we all know how how how what
a difference maker that was and
Verlander is now a leader in that locker
room on that clubhouse where he's
basically put in a position having
full blast anybody that's been involved
in domestic violence and now here comes
a Sunnah
under under suspension still is this
gonna be a problem in that in that
Clubhouse do you think in good news well
could be you know what just that this
screams to me rich it is what it still
is and it always probably will be when
it comes deep down to it it's about
winning baseball games right now Sunnah
has a hearing he has one more game I
believe August 1st tomorrow the
suspension is lifted but he also has
some legalities that he has to get
through he served a seventy five game
suspension and I know Justin Verlander
and after the game yesterday he had to
dress this he makes a very strong
statement against Roberto Osuna and
against the best of violence and I get
that I understand it it's going to be an
interesting situation when or zouna if
he does if this goes through and the
legal process plays itself out this is
why I guess I what just is so crazy
about the game and where the world we
live in right now right now he'll be
he's saved to serve the seventy five
game suspension I wonder if the Astros
make this deal if he wasn't allowed to
participate no Posey there's no chance
tonight right Robinson Cano now has got
popped for 80 games right when he comes
back he's not going to be able to play
in the postseason but Roberto Ozuna will
and I I don't want to I can't say this
for the Astros but I find it hard to
believe rich that they would pull the
trigger on this deal if they knew he
wasn't able to pitch in the postseason
because they don't need to help to get
to the postseason they need to help in
the backend and they're wrote well they
that that was their Achilles heel pretty
much last year and the thought maybe
McCullers does a the same thing this
time around that he did last year to
help him out with that there's no
question Dan if he was an unavailable in
October they don't need Osuna to get to
October they're getting October I mean
that's that's that's a fact yeah it's an
interesting dilemma and from an
organization you know they asked us to
have little came on record yes they're
saying that they have a zero-tolerance
policy and but yet they're they're
willing to give a guy a second chance
and I get that and I totally understand
that but I just find it hard to believe
that they would have been really
to make this move if F September at the
end of September he wasn't going to be
able to play in the postseason so that's
what this is about anyway you look at it
slice it and dice it if there's anybody
I guess it can handle anything in the
clubhouse it should be AJ Hinch anyway
and and and then put that on his plate
dan always love our chats let's chat
again - do this again before the
postseason starts well please let's do
it before you know August hits the
midway point always love check you got
it you got it - and another homerun call
from kid Carlos Stanton - do you want to
just do Mike just give that - great
deadline better Dan please act
requesting a John sterling home run call
that may or may not be real I'm just
giving that out there it may or may not
be real you got it Mike del - folk
played for Dan please act please here on
the Rich Eisen show you got a mic is
that a yes or a No
you got to give me some sort of heads-up
Mike Mike my words he leads off second
and here's the worm - day
[Applause]
a two-run bomb as all
it's judge Brockman here's the one get
told to suck it you got it dad you got
it of course the trade deadline makes
that moot point now it's a moot court
cos drew rice comes the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience